[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera bienvenidos aquí américa el
programa donde revisaremos en
profundidad las historias y las noticias
de nuestro continente
en esta edición hablaremos de cómo se
encienden de nuevo las protestas en eeuu
por las acciones de la policía esta vez
se reaviva el descontento por la muerte
del latino adam tollet y del
afroamericano down right durante los
procedimientos de las autoridades otro
de los temas centrales en eeuu es la
ratificación del presidente joe biden
sobre el retiro de las tropas
estadounidenses de afganistán más de
2.500 uniformados saldrán del país de
medio oriente a partir del primero de
mayo luego de una guerra que marcó tanto
a los afganos como a los militares
estadounidenses
en haití no para la violencia el país
está inmerso en una espiral de
secuestros que salió de nuevo a la luz
con la retención de 10 personas los
nuevos secuestrados son tres civiles
cinco curas y dos monjas incluidos dos
ciudadanos franceses este es el episodio
más reciente del gran incremento que han
tenido los secuestros en la nación del
caribe
comencemos entonces en eeuu esta semana
ha sido bastante agitada por cuenta de
los operativos policiales la primera ola
de protestas comenzó en el estado de
minnesota luego de que la uniformada que
imponer le disparara al afroamericano
down er white de 20 años durante un
retén de tránsito pocos días después la
polémica por las acciones de las
autoridades se volvió a encender pero
esta vez en chicago pues los
funcionarios de la ciudad publicaron un
vídeo en el que se ve como el oficial
eric stearman le dispara a adam toledo
pocos segundos después de que éste
pusiera sus manos en alto toledo sólo
tenía 13 años y era de origen hispano
los dos episodios coinciden con el
tiempo en el que directo a bing responde
ante los tribunales por la muerte de
georg floyd advertimos que las
siguientes imágenes son fuertes y pueden
herir la sensibilidad de nuestra
audiencia
a donde wright lo detuvieron el 11 de
abril en las afueras de minneapolis
donde murió george floyd en un operativo
policial todavía es confuso lo que pasó
la ex policía kimberly potter dice que
detuvo a wright en un retén de tránsito
y que se dio cuenta de que el
afroamericano de 20 años faltó a una
audiencia por un delito anterior
y poder asegura que se equivocó y que en
vez de usar su pistola paralizante
disparó su arma de fuego white murió al
instante las autoridades dicen que fue
un accidente pero para otros fue un acto
racista de la policía
primero disparan y luego hacen las
preguntas y después se salen con la suya
así que esto es extremo pero siempre se
les ocurre con una forma de justificar
una y otra vez la matanza de
afroamericanos en eeuu
el caso desató las protestas frente a la
estación de policía de brooklyn center
en el estado de minnesota el gobierno
local respondió con un toque de queda y
con el despliegue de la guardia nacional
pocos días después las autoridades de
chicago publicaron un vídeo en las
imágenes se ve como el oficial
eric steele man corre detrás de adam
toledo un adolescente de 13 años de
ascendencia latina
toledo levanta las manos y pocos
segundos después stillman le dispara las
autoridades creen que el menor tenía un
arma algo que niegan sus defensores
dos vídeos speak fuerte mi show estos
vídeos hablan por sí solos
durante su último segundo de vida no
tenía un arma en la mano con energía
el oficial de grito muéstrame las manos
adam obedeció y se dio la vuelta tenía
las manos vacías cuando recibió un
disparo en el pecho a manos del oficial
aunque adán toledo murió el 29 de marzo
su fallecimiento se conoció públicamente
en la misma semana en la que eeuu
reaviva el debate sobre las acciones
policiales
sigamos con eeuu el presidente joe biden
ratificó que a partir del primero de
mayo las 2500 tropas estadounidenses que
quedan en afganistán saldrán del país el
mandatario dijo que los afganos son
quienes deben dirigir su propia nación y
que ya era hora de acabar con la guerra
más larga que ha tenido el país
norteamericano a propósito de esta
decisión en el siguiente reporte les
contamos el precio que tuvieron que
pagar los militares estadounidenses
luego de invadir afganistán
he llegado a la conclusión de que es
hora de poner fin a la guerra más larga
de eeuu es hora de que las tropas que
estadounidenses regresen a casa así el
presidente de eeuu anunció que a partir
del primero de mayo los 2500 militares
estadounidenses que quedan en afganistán
comenzarán a retirarse la promesa es que
para el 11 de septiembre en el
aniversario del atentado a las torres
gemelas ya no habrá ningún uniformado
norteamericano allí esto marca el fin de
una guerra que ha durado cerca de 20
años y que trajo dolor y sangre para
todos los bandos pero a pesar del
esfuerzo algunos veteranos creen que los
estadounidenses olvidaron para que
invadieron afganistán todo poder es
comandante de la reserva de la marina de
eeuu y cuenta que algunos de sus
compatriotas ni siquiera reconocen la
bandera habana
hay un término común que usamos olvidado
hasta porque el público estadounidense
ha olvidado que hemos estado allí
entonces es difícil mantenerse
involucrado en una guerra cuando el
público estadounidense ni siquiera se da
cuenta de cuál es nuestra misión cuáles
son nuestras metas y qué estamos
haciendo
de eeuu invadió afganistán desde octubre
de 2001 con la promesa de derrocar a los
talibanes del poder luego de que ellos
protegieron a osama bin laden pero no
todos los veteranos creen que salieron
victoriosos
de la capacidad para sobrevivir a
nosotros
tú tienes los relojes nosotros tenemos
el tiempo
eeuu se gastó cerca de 2 billones de
dólares durante los combates alrededor
de 2500 de sus militares murieron en los
operativos y amigar aunque la cifra es
incomparable frente a los 157 mil
afganos que fallecieron en la guerra de
los cuales más de 43 mil eran civiles
ahora vamos con haití el pasado 11 de
abril un grupo armado secuestró a siete
religiosos incluidos dos franceses y
también rapto a tres civiles más la
policía asegura que la pandilla 400 más
ojos es quien está detrás de todo y que
ellos piden un millón de dólares por el
rescate los clérigos fueron secuestrados
en el área de jugada de busquets en el
nordeste de la capital puerto príncipe
mientras se preparaban para darle la
bienvenida a un nuevo párroco el hecho
encendió aún más las protestas contra el
presidente job en el mois a quien acusan
de no hacer lo suficiente para frenar la
hora de violencia en el país caribeño
y es que la situación es tan preocupante
que el secretario general de naciones
unidas le presentó un informe al consejo
de seguridad de la onu en febrero de
este año para advertirles sobre lo que
ocurre en haití según el organismo la
inseguridad empeoró y el gobierno es
incapaz de detener a los secuestradores
que están desenfrenados de hecho esta
fue una de las razones principales por
las que las protestas aumentaron al
punto que solo en el segundo semestre de
2020 hubo 84 manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de moix el informe de la onu
también señala que los secuestros se
dispararon el año pasado pues en 2019 78
personas fueron retenidas en haití
mientras que esta cifra fue de 234
secuestrados en 2020 esto representa un
incremento del 200% en tan sólo un año
y 2021 tampoco pinta bien la monja de
chance idea fue detenida el 8 de enero
mientras estaba en su casa el 20 de
febrero un grupo armado rapto en puerto
príncipe a dos cineastas dominicanos los
hermanos michel enríquez y antonio
campusano y al intérprete haitiano
júnior albert el primero de abril el
secuestro fue en una iglesia evangélica
con cuatro víctimas incluido el pastor y
el hecho más reciente fue la retención
de tres civiles y siete clérigos el 11
de abril en la capital de haití aunque
la mayoría de los raptados en 2021 ya
fueron liberados la violencia no cesa
continuemos con otras de las noticias
más relevantes que han pasado en el
continente americano esta semana en
brasil el supremo tribunal ratificó la
decisión que ya había tomado el tribunal
de curitiba sobre el ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva en otras palabras
el político ya no tendrá que enfrentar
las dos sentencias que tenía en contra y
que le daban más de 20 años de cárcel
además le deja el camino libre para que
se pueda presentar a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2022
en tres países andinos las votaciones de
llamado super domingo electoral marcan
una nueva tendencia en ecuador y en
bolivia la noticia es la derrota de los
dos políticos más influyentes en esos
países el candidato presidencial al que
apoyaba rafael correa perdió ante un ex
banquero conservador mientras que el
partido de evo morales se quedó
únicamente con las gobernaciones de tres
de los nueve departamentos bolivianos
incluso perdió en la paz contrario a
esto los comicios de perú mostraron que
el fujimorismo sigue vivo y que podría
repotenciarse si keiko fujimori supera
en la segunda vuelta presidencial al
maestro de izquierda pedro castillo
américa es el continente donde
asesinaron a más defensores de derechos
humanos durante el 2020 el nuevo informe
de la organización front line defenders
sostiene que en la región mataron al 86
por ciento de todos los defensores
asesinados en el mundo el peor de los
países es colombiano allí ocurrieron más
de la mitad de todos los homicidios de
defensores humanos que hubo en el mundo
entero desde que se firmó el acuerdo de
paz en 2016 en promedio un defensor es
asesinado cada 25 días ahora sigamos en
cuba porque el ministerio de agricultura
anunció una medida que catalogó como
inédita las autoridades permitirán que
los ganaderos puedan sacrificar reses
para vender y consumir carne lo novedoso
de la decisión es que rompe con las
antiguas normativas pues en la ayuda se
penalizaba hasta con 10 años de cárcel
pero ahora levantaron esa restricción
para que los productores puedan
enfrentar la escasez de alimentos que
hay en cuba y que se agudizó durante la
pandemia del cobi 19 en un país que
importa el 80 por ciento de lo que con
sus chaquetas maría tiene que
convertirse porque si no al final si
seguimos como la masa que tenemos ahora
tenemos que hablarle claro a nuestro
pueblo no no vamos a vender no vamos a
tener de cannes ya que aquí
incrementales la producción o sea que un
producto cuando cumplen cuando cumple
compromiso que tiene como encargo
estatal puede entonces sacrificar en un
animal parte sólo consumo o vender para
incrementar la oferta de carne bovina a
la población terminemos nuestro programa
de hoy con la imagen de la semana aunque
todavía está en construcción este
monumento en el sur de brasil promete
marcar un hito en la historia del país
el llamado cristo protector romperá el
récord de altura que tiene el famoso
cristo de corcovado que mira a río de
ella
la nueva escultura medirá 5 metros más
para un total de 43 metros de alto
la estatua gigante la están construyendo
desde 2019 en la ciudad de encantado en
el estado de río grande del sur y según
la asociación de los amigos de cristo
que coordina el trabajo el nuevo
monumento estará listo para finales de
este año
así terminamos nuestro programa de hoy
gracias por acompañarme en aquí américa
recuerden que pueden seguirme a través
de las redes sociales que ven en sus
pantallas soy maría clara calle por
natalia cabrera
quédense conectados para más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]